the term fairy nowadays for the most
part has positive connotations and from
the media we consume you'd be forgiven
for thinking fairies such as tinkerbell
or the fairy godmother or the textbook
definition although they do technically
fall under the definition of what a
fairy can be i think it's best if we
take this very disney-esque depiction
and ignore it for now which then begs
the question what is a fairy
terms such as fey fairfolk or fairy have
been used across many european cultures
and they refer to physical beings or
spirits with supernatural qualities so
given that very broad definition a fairy
can essentially be any mythical creature
it's not a specific type of creature but
more so a term used to categorize a
whole bunch of creatures hence why fairy
tales contain all manner of magical
creatures from dragons elves goblins
dwarves and of course fairies
sometimes they have a close connection
to humans and are fairly benevolent and
other times their stories are much
darker than the fairy tales you may find
today in order to understand these
origins and why they may not have always
been so bright and cheery we need to
examine the different types of fairy
so
oh
[Music]
in scotland the fairies are classified
into two categories which are now
commonly used in several other countries
they are divided into the sealy court
and the unsealy court
the seelie court are the fairies that
wish to help humans they are described
as the most beautiful and vibrant of
fairies
they seek out humans for favors and in
return offer assistance when needed
through blessings and wishes if they are
offended by a human they will always
attempt to rectify the situation these
fairies are commonly associated with the
spring and summer as they prefer to be
out in the light
the unseelie court are their much darker
counterparts they are hideous and have
no interest in being friendly they are
most active in the autumn and winter as
they prefer to travel in the dark
they dabble in dark magic and will harm
humans merely to entertain themselves
they also routinely steal human children
as they themselves are unable to
reproduce
fairies can also be categorized as
trooping solitary and domesticated
trooping refers to organized groups of
fairies fairies that have formed their
own society and have their own rules and
laws to govern by
solitary fairies prefer to be alone and
are almost always tricksters or sinister
creatures domesticated fairies are
normally part of a household in exchange
for their labor and service they are
given food and a place to stay
fairies in general are normally
described as very small human-like
creatures with wings however their size
can vary as many of them can imitate
humans in form we also have many fairies
who do not have wings so there is no
one-size-fits-all description for
fairies
the changeling is a type of fairy common
in all sorts of european folklore they
were left behind by fairies when a human
had been stolen commonly a child
the changeling would mimic the missing
person's appearance although this
disguise was never perfect a superior
intellect to a child of the same age
could be hidden but facial hair long
teeth and abnormally large beady eyes
may make you question if this was really
your child
the changeling story is quite sad with
some rather dark undertones it's common
for them to be referred to as oaths
because they were the deformed offspring
of fairies and elves they were shunned
and never accepted when the fairies
found a child they wanted to take in as
their own they would kidnap the child
and leave the changeling in their place
these children were taken for a
multitude of reasons some were taken as
servants some to punish the parents who
had wronged the fairies and others were
loved and raised as the replacement for
the changeling
if the changeling was discovered there
are a number of ways one could attempt
to have their child returned causing the
changeling to laugh was one way and then
we have the not so subtle approach of
torturing the changeling this was used
as a common excuse and explanation for
child abuse especially amongst children
who were born with some kind of
deformity
it also ties into the idea that taking
the changeling into the wilderness to be
reclaimed by the fairies may also work
at a time where providing enough food
for a household was a struggle for many
every member of that household would
have to contribute
changelings were seen as having a
voracious appetite as well as several
deformities which resulted in a lack of
contribution and so they threatened the
family's ability to sustain itself thus
the close links to child abuse
abandonment and infant mortality rates
there are also stories of fairies
kidnapping adults to marry into their
families and mothers to help raise their
fairy children in these cases an
enchanted log was left behind which
assumed the appearance of the person who
had been stolen
shortly after this log replacement would
become sick and die forcing the family
to bury their lost loved one none the
wiser of the swap that has just occurred
the case of bridget cleary is probably
the most famous involving a changeling
related murder the events took place in
ireland where bridget had been killed by
her husband in 1895
who had then set her body on fire
claiming that she had been taken by the
fairies bridget had been diagnosed with
bronchitis
her condition was severe enough that she
had a priest administer her last rights
given her sudden illness bridget's
husband and father accused her of being
a fairy sent to replace the real bridget
in order to cast out the fairy bridget
was carried into the fireplace
this was done because in ireland it was
believed that placing a changeling into
a fireplace would cause them to jump up
the chimney and return the missing
person
the changeling story is a sad one of
abandonment and neglect
leprechauns are most likely a type of
fairy you've heard of before they were
seen as mischievous creatures but they
also preferred to act alone much of
their time was spent making shoes as
most of them were cobblers by trade
today's leprechauns are fairly close in
appearance with just one major
difference the colours worn the iconic
green was actually never a thing prior
to the 20th century before leprechauns
would wear red jackets
david russell mccannelly wrote a book
titled irish wonders which details all
sorts of fairies ghosts and creatures
found in irish folklore it was his
belief that every mythology had good and
evil spirits to him the leprechaun was a
relic of ireland's pagan mythology it
was neither holy good nor entirely evil
his take on the leprechaun is by far one
of the most detailed i've come across
by birth the leprechaun is of low
descent his father being an evil spirit
and his mother a degenerate fairy
by nature he is a mischief maker the
puck of the emerald isle
he is of diminutive size about three
feet high and distressed in a little red
jacket with red breeches buckled at the
knee grey or black stockings and a hat
in the style of a century ago over a
little old withered face
he also goes on to say that fairies who
live in large groups wear the color
green whereas solitary fairies such as
leprechauns prefer red
if you were able to physically catch a
leprechaun they were compelled to show
you the location of their gold which was
buried in mounds of dirt however they
had plenty of tricks along the way in
one story a farmer caught a leprechaun
and demanded he take him to his gold the
leprechaun did so that night however
when the farmer ordered him to start
digging he pleaded to let him go because
he had no spade he was no use to the
farmer at this point as he already knew
where the gold was the leprechaun took a
stick and placed it into the mud and
then threw his hat on top the spot has
been marked you can come back with a
spade and take all of the gold for
yourself now please let me go
satisfied the farmer let the leprechaun
go and return the next morning with a
spade ready to dig up the gold however
the farmer returned to a bog full of
sticks and hats placed on top of them
finding the gold now would take forever
he had been well and truly outsmarted
mcconnelly also mentions that
leprechauns avoid friendships with other
fairies and have no interest in marriage
or family some stories point to this
being because they were exiled and
others merely believe that leprechauns
just prefer to be alone
remaining on the topic of solitary house
fairies we have the boggarts and
brownies when everybody in the house is
asleep the brownie will come out and
perform various tasks and chores in
return for their service they ask for an
offering of some kind this was normally
food and drink with brownies having a
particular taste for cake milk and cream
similar to the brownie you have the
hobgoblin which was also seen as a
helpful house spirit
brownies were seen as a sign of
prosperity for the household they
inhabit but they were also notorious for
their unpredictable temperament they
were extremely easy to upset
something as harmless as moving the
broom or changing their surroundings can
leave them in a fit of rage
if they are not calmed down or appeased
they will leave the house and look for
another this is actually the best
scenario because the alternative is the
brownie becomes a boggart essentially an
evil brownie they cause chaos around the
house they steal and move things around
they mess with pets and cause milk to
sour they even jump into your bed to
pull on your ears and just behave like
creepy weirdos
boguts will follow families wherever
they go so moving house doesn't solve
the problem placing a pile of salt
outside the door to a room and leaving a
horseshoe on the door handle of your
front door is said to keep boggarts from
entering
pixies are a type of fairy common in the
united kingdom particularly in devon and
cornwall some of you may remember the
cornish pixies in harry potter most
pixies were believed to live underground
in large mounds and stone circles for
the most part they were considered
harmless and benign childlike in both
stature and demeanor they were playful
and mischievous
a singular pixie was a rare sight as
they often gathered in very large groups
dancing singing and playing pranks on
nearby humans
there are stories of pixies kidnapping
children and punishing humans however
there are far more that describe them as
being fond of humans especially children
and those who meant them no harm this
stretched as far as playing with
children giving them blessings and even
granting them wishes in some fairy tales
the modern depiction of a pixie is a
small creature with pointed ears and
wings somewhat elf-like
in the victorian era they were depicted
as wearing not much more than old rags
however giving a pixie new clothing was
a very good way to make a friend of one
the rise of christianity in britain
caused stories of pixies to change
slightly pixies were then explained as
being the souls of unbaptized children
who had died shortly after their funeral
they would change into pixies instead of
passing on they remained in this plane
with the same childlike innocence
however they were trapped in pixie limbo
a type of creature that we see in many
cultures today takes the form of the
irish banshee the old irish roughly
meaning woman of the fairy mound
banshees appear as both young and
elderly women their eyes red and sore
from the continuous weeping they are
known for the elderly banshees are quite
short with a green dress and grey cloak
the more youthful banshees are sometimes
rather tall with red silver or golden
hair a white dress and a ghostly
complexion
a banshee appears when a family member
has died
their screaming or wailing is the first
sign you may already be aware of the
situation but in cases of long distance
the banshee is always seen as a bearer
of bad news a common explanation was
that banshees were the ghosts of young
women who had died a brutal death
if that woman was mistreated or had a
deep hatred for her family then they
would stick around full of anger waiting
for those they hated to also die
more common are these stories of women
who died too early and that had a strong
connection to their family and so they
remain or linger to watch over them the
songs of these banshees were much calmer
but were also full of sorrow
this ties to the profession of keening
and the term keening woman which we do
see in scotland and ireland
essentially keaning is a way of paying
respect to the dead it is a vocal ritual
of sorts performed at wakes and funerals
some may compare it to singing however
it's not quite the same there is vocal
repetition and rhythm in both voice and
movement but none of this is planned
more importantly there is also what some
would compare to a banshee's wailing
sometimes banshees would predict a death
and appear early the person whose fate
had been predicted may hear the banshee
song days before anyone else when
numerous banshees were seen in one place
the death was considered to be someone
of greater significance than normal it's
fair to say that banshees aren't
considered evil or malicious fairies but
given these circumstances that build up
to seeing one it's understandable why
you would rather avoid them
another commonly held belief is that
fairies were once pagan deities as their
belief and worship began to disappear
they were demoted to just mythical
beings the church echoes a similar idea
however fairies in this case were once
angels who had been demoted the story
states that during a revolt in heaven
god ordered the gates to be shut those
inside remained angels those in hell
became demons and those in between
became fairies
eventually by the 17th century the
church began to see all fairies as
demons the brownies and hobgoblins which
were once seen as friendly house spirits
were now seen by many as wicked goblins
even the idea of fairies had become
associated with acts of witchcraft and
thus those spreading these stories were
punished in a similar way
the idea of fairies being or
representing the souls of the dead
appears quite often in both scotland and
ireland there is a fairy known as the
slough or sluch that flies through the
air during halloween this is a cloudy
mess largely composed of the souls of
the dead flying together almost like a
flock of birds
pre-christianity they were considered
some of the most vile members of the
unseelie court wherever they went the
feeling of hopelessness and sadness
followed humans would avoid them at all
costs
the church then gave the slough a more
physical or human description
rather than fairies they became the
souls of sinners and those who refused
to repent they were cursed to fly
through the air together for eternity
now as we've seen today the word fairy
is very much a blanket term used by many
cultures to categorize a group of
creatures within their folklore these
creatures can have fairly joyous stories
but they can also be part of very tragic
tales
if you have any stories of fairies
movies tv shows or books where you
enjoyed their depiction feel free to
share those in the comment section
as always
i've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
you